vous l'avez peut-être remarqué plusieurs
panneaux d'entrée de ville sont à
l'envers depuis hier soir les
responsables des agriculteurs
d'indrloire qui dénonce selon eux les
aberrations du système qui serait
responsable de la concurrence déloyale
qu'ils subissent face aux producteurs
étrangers l'opération s'appelle on
marche sur la tête d'où les panneaux
retournés un mouvement national auquel
se sont joints les jeunes agriculteurs
37 et la Fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricooles Lucas
Chopin non retournez pas votre écran
vous n'hallucinez pas veignier saintépin
manteland et plus d'une centaine
d'autres communes se sont réveillé ce
matin avec la tête à l'envers et si
certains habitants n'ont rien remarqué
non absolument pas depuis quand c'était
retourné pas du tout B alors là vraiment
pour le coup je m'en suis même pas rendu
compte en fait d'autres se sont posé des
questions oui effectivement j'ai
constaté que les panneaux avaient été
retournés mais je ne sais pas pourquoi
telle est la question en fait oui j'en
ai entendu parler aux informations pour
sensibiliser les gens certainement sur
sur quelque chose mais je me souviens
plus non si c'est désormais au villees
de redonner du sens au panneau certains
maires comme ici à liigueil préfèrent
relativiser ça peut poser quelques
petits problèmes dans des communes où le
nombre d'employés est beaucoup
moindre bon un coup bon on a regardé il
a il y a pas de détérioration à
proprement parler prenons ça par le bon
côté des choses il y a des choses s fois
pire monsieur voilà et à ce petit jeu
les jeunes agriculteurs et la FNSE appel
coupable si les fait prêtent à sourire
ils sont en réalité le symbole d'une
souffrance celle d'une frange des
agriculteurs qui dit crouler sous les
normes jacher imposé manque d'accès à
l'eau concurrence forcée avec d'autres
pays européens pour la fnsea37 le monde
agricole marche sur la tête on nous
donne des règles européennes qu'on
démultiplie en France ce qui ne va pas
du tout en fait avec le fonctionnement
de nos exploitations mais aussi avec la
souveraineté alimentaire on nous demande
toujours plus alors que les autres pays
eux appliquent juste les règles
européennes
et donc non on moins de pression et par
contre nous on va acheter dans leur pays
de quoi de quoi se nourrir les Français
je trouve que c'est
abérrant si les autorités ne réagissent
pas à cet acte Pacifique par des mesures
concrètes en faveur des agriculteurs la
FNSEA annonce d'ors et déjà que d'autres
actions d'Ance
suivront